When the book had nits are a Babylon burned the temple and destroyed Jerusalem.
The initial reaction was one of overwhelming grief and sadness.
And that's represented primarily in the book of lamentations.
It's a very short book of Durgin that lament the loss of Jerusalem,
um,
as the death of a beloved person.
And it's traditionally attributed to Jeremiah.
The Bible itself doesn't make this claim.
It's an old tradition.
It may have a risen,
however,
because of all of the prophets,
Jeremiah is the one who reveals the most to us about his personal suffering and
grief.
And because he was present as an eye witness at the destruction,
there's no real logical development of ideas in limitations,
primarily because it's structured by an artificial device.
There are five chapters and four of the chapters are acrostic poems.
This means that each verse,
or sometimes a series of verses begins with a letter of the alphabet and
sequence.
So in chapter three you have three versus per letter of the alphabet.
But this kind of a cross stick poetic formation gives the poem a kind of formal
unity at the same time that it has no logical unity or logical flow.
And it's been pointed out that that a form is particularly appropriate for an
expression of grief that is too profound or too all encompassing to be logical.
The limitations over Jerusalem resemble very much David's limitations.
Oversaw the mourner spends time contrasting the former splendor of the beloved
to his or her presence state.
And we have lots of ancient near eastern prototypes or this kind of limitation
limitations over destroyed cities,
which are understood as the result of the deities decision to abandon the city
and in limitations were given a very detailed picture of the great suffering
that accompanied the final collapse.
Limitations.
One one.
Alas,
lonely sits the city once great with people.
She,
that was great.
Among nations is become like a widow.
The princess among states is become a thrall.
A chapter four.
Um,
alas,
the gold is dulled,
debased.
The finest gold,
the sacred gems are spilled at every street corner.
The Precious Children of Zion once valued as gold,
alas,
they are accounted as earthen pots,
work of a potter's hands.
Even jackals offer the breast and suckle.
They're young,
but my poor people has turned cruel like ostriches of the desert.
The tongue of the suckling cleaves to its Palette for thirst.
Little children beg for bread,
none.
Give them a morsel.
Those who feasted on Dante's life famished in the streets,
those who were reared in purple have embraced refuse heaps.
The guilt of my poor people exceeded the inequity of Saddam,
which was overthrown in a moment without a hand striking it.
Her elect,
we're pure than snow,
wiser than milk.
Their limbs were readier than Carl.
Their bodies were like Sapphire again,
the description of the physical beauty of the beloved and now their faces are
blacker than suit.
They are not recognized in the street.
Their skin has shriveled on their bones.
It has become dry as would better off where the slain of the sword.
Then those slain by famine who pined away as the wounded for lack of the fruits
of the field with their own hands.
Tenderhearted women have cooked their children,
such became their fare in the disaster of my poor people.
The poet here though does adopt the standard Deuteronomistic interpretation of
events which infers sin from suffering and therefore harps on the sin and the
uncleanness of Jerusalem that brought on this calamity and there their guilt
exceeded the iniquity of Sodom in the passage we just read,
and this is a strategy that of course justifies God.
The poet singles out the corrupt priests,
the corrupt profits for blame.
He attacks the popular ideology of the Inviolability of Zion.
Israel's many sins or what caused the off way to pour out his wrath and
destroyed Jerusalem utterly and the descriptions of Yahweh's wrath,
anger,
his consuming rage.
These are some of the most powerful and most violent,
uh,
poetry in the Hebrew Bible.
They tend to divert attention,
in fact,
from the People's guilt and focus attention on their suffering.
Children crying for bread,
children starving to death.
Women raped men abused.
In chapter three the poet's switches into the first person.
So Jerusalem is speaking like one who's pursued and abused,
beaten by an angry and violent master.
Chapter three I am the man who has known affliction under the Rod of his wrath.
Me.
He drove on and on and unrelieved darkness on none but me.
He brings down his hand again and again without cease.
He has worn away my flesh and skin.
He has shattered my bones all around me.
He has built misery and hardship.
He has made me dwell in darkness like those long dead.
He has walled me in and I cannot break out.
He has weighed me down with chains and when I cry and plead,
he shuts out my prayer.
He has walled in my ways with human blocks.
He has made my pads Amaz.
He is a lurking bear to me,
Elian in hiding.
He has forced me off my way and mangled me.
He has left me numb remarkably violent passage and in another remarkable
passage,
the poet describes God as refusing to hear the prayers of Israel.
He no longer can forgive.
He simply has to punish.
This is in a chapter three as well versus 42 to 45 we have transgressed and
rebelled,
but you have not forgiven.
You have clothed yourself in anger and pursued us.
You have slain without pity.
You have screened yourself off with a cloud that no prayer may pass through.
You have made us filth and refuse in the midst of the peoples,
right?
So God is simply refusing to even hear Israel's prayers.
So there's this emphasis,
not so much on Israel's guilt,
but on Israel's tremendous suffering.
God's hardheartedness.
The poem ends with a plea of reconciliation and Chapter Five Verses 19 to 22 but
you,
oh Lord are enthroned forever.
Your throne endures through the ages.
Why have you forgotten us?
Utterly forsaken us for all time.
Take us back,
oh Lord to yourself and let us come back.
Renew our days as of old.
For truly you have rejected us,
bitterly raged against us.
Take us back,
oh Lord to yourself and let us come back.
Renew our days as of old limitations represents one response to the fall of
Jerusalem.
It's an overwhelming sense of loss.
Grief,
misery.
I'm sort of shocked.
Um,
a sense of shock to it.
Guts treatment and also a longing to return,
a longing for renewal and reconciliation.
But the 200 years of following the destruction would prove to be a time,
a very critical time of transition.
And Israelite literature in this period reflects the Israelites struggle with
the philosophical and religious challenge of the destruction.
How could the disastrous events be explained?
We've already seen the response of the Deuteronomistic school.
Israel was collectively punished for idolatry.
We've seen,
uh,
that history simply reflects justice on a national and international level in
this view.
We've also seen the response of a zeal.
He,
he promoted the idea of a continued relationship with God in exile and was
awaiting a fantastic restoration,
a redesign of human nature.
We've seen the response of Second Isaiah,
which emphasizes the universal significance of Israel suffering universal
mission for Israel for both Zq and the author of Second Isaiah Israel surface.
Uh,
suffering is serving a purpose in the divine plan.
It's necessary.
Israel needs purification and redemption and that will prepare her for a new
role in world history.
But there are other responses as well,
and they're found in the material that's collected in the third section of the
Hebrew Bible.
That's the section referred to really is to have him and Hebrew simply means
writings,
written things.
So it's,
it's sort of a miscellanea catchall phrase.
Uh,
and the final portion of the course is going to be devoted now to that third
section.
So Tara Nivi more profits and neck to Veeam or writings.
Um,
next time I'm going to discuss the problem of dating many of the works that are
in this third section.
The writings for now will suffice it to say that while some of the books in this
third section of the Bible may have predated the exile,
they became canonical.
They became authoritative for the community in the Postig Zelig period,
and therefore served as a prism through which to view and come to grips with
Israel's history.
So we're going to turn today,
first of all,
to an examination of the book,
three books that represent the wisdom tradition,
what's referred to as a wisdom literature,
a wisdom tradition in ancient Israel.
And the wisdom books of the Hebrew Bible are proverbs,
job and Ecclesiastes.
These,
um,
Israelite wisdom literature belongs to a much wider,
uh,
and broad,
broad wisdom legacy or tradition in the ancient near east.
There's very little in biblical wisdom literature apart from its monotheism that
lacks a parallel in the wisdom literature of Egypt or Mesopotamia.
So ancient near eastern wisdom literature is literature that's characterized by
a praise of human intelligence applied to understanding the ways of the world,
the ways of society.
It tends to contain a traditional advice,
advice that's been found to be tried and true.
It tends to be very individually oriented,
right?
But at the same time,
quite universal and humanistic in its orientation as well.
And in keeping with this style Israelite wisdom literature doesn't really speak
to the particular historical condition of Israel.
It speaks to the general human condition.
It makes no claim to having been divinely revealed,
no special claim to having been conveyed by a prophet or by Moses.
It's simply observational wisdom.
All right,
uh,
advice and counsel that can be weighed or confirmed or disputed by experience.
And again,
if you were to simply to open up the book of proverbs and read something in
there,
unless it had the word,
yeah way,
you wouldn't know that it didn't come from some Egyptian wisdom literature of
Mesopotamian wisdom literature.
There are various types of wisdom material,
um,
scholars of sort of classified the wisdom material into three main categories.
The Hebrew word for wisdom,
which is a word [inaudible].
It literally means skill and probably refers to the skill of living well or
living properly.
And the three types of wisdom literature that we find are what we would call
clan or family wisdom.
These materials tend to be common sense aphorisms and observations,
the kinds of things that are common to all cultures.
They're scattered around the Hebrew Bible,
but most of them,
um,
are contained in the book of proverbs.
So,
for example,
proverbs 15,
17,
better a meal of vegetables where there is love than a fattened docs where there
is hate,
right?
It's kind of thing you can imagine,
you know,
your grandmother saying Chapter 20,
verse 14,
bad,
says the buyer,
but having moved off,
he congratulates himself or 26,
14,
the door turns on its hinge and the lazy man on his bed,
right?
And neither of them really gets anywhere.
And 25,
25 like cold water to a parched throat is uh,
is good news from a distant land.
And many of the proverbs we classify as clan or family wisdom are,
are very,
are parental right.
They tend to sound as if they're being said to a son.
Uh,
not so much a daughter,
but to a son.
The second category of wisdom literature is what we call court wisdom.
And,
uh,
we have a lot of this from Egypt.
A great deal of court wisdom came from Egypt.
It served the needs of the court.
It tends to be bureaucratic advice,
administrative advice,
career advice,
instruction on manners or tact,
how to be diplomatic,
how to live well on prosper,
practical wisdom.
So for example,
proverbs 24 27 puts your external affairs in order,
get ready what you have in the field and then build yourself a home or 2123 he
who guards his mouth and tongue guards himself from trouble,
right?
Tact 1114 for want of strategy and army falls.
But victory comes with much planning or 12 one he who loves discipline,
loves knowledge.
He who spurns reproof is a brutish man.
And then the third category of wisdom literature is what we might call more
freewheeling,
um,
existential reflection or,
or probing reflection,
reflective probing into the critical problems of human existence.
And I'm going to talk about that in much more detail as we get to the book of
job.
Now,
as I mentioned before,
all of these types of wisdom literature tend to be very universalistic,
humanistic,
a historical,
there's nothing particularly is particularly Israelite about them.
There's no mention of the exodus.
There's no mention of Sinai or Moses or covenant or,
or any of the early narratives of the nation.
And they are paralleled in great abundance in the writings of other ancient near
eastern cultures.
Sometimes there's an attempt to connect wisdom specifically with belief and your
way.
Um,
but biblical wisdom like ancient near eastern wisdom generally grounds morality
on nonspecific notions of prudence and God fearing and a sort of nonspecific way
rather than on the historical covenant with Yahweh.
So let's look into a little more detail.
Look at the book of proverbs and a little more detail.
Proverbs is the classic book of Wisdom.
It contains some material of great antiquity,
even though the book in its final probably reached its final form only and
Postig Zelig Times.
Surely a great deal of it is a much older,
there are many affinities between proverbs and Egyptian and Canaanite wisdom
literature.
So it suggests that Israel,
uh,
assimilated wisdom material from the wider environment.
Um,
the chief aim of proverbs seems to be the inculcation of wisdom as the means to
social tranquility and a happy life.
Young people should learn to master their impulses.
They should lead productive and sensible lives.
Many of the maxims are intended to educate sons.
There's no mention of daughters here.
And a good deal of the first nine chapters is formally pedagogical,
clearly pedagogical.
And it can be compared quite productively with some Egyptian writings that we
have from the third millennium,
the Egyptian teaching of a minimum oh pit or the Babylonian councils of wisdom.
Tremendous,
uh,
parallels among these works.
But these first nine chapters warn against the seductions of foreign women and
they urge young men to pursue wisdom and wisdom here is figured almost type
hypothesized,
right?
Almost at an attribute or characteristic that's almost put into a concrete human
form.
Wisdom is figured as a virtuous woman who promises insight and council.
This woman was created before all other created things and wisdom again,
figured as a woman assisted,
yeah,
way in the creation and the ordering,
I should say the ordering of the universe.
Wisdom was with God at that time.
Proverbs values hard work and diligence and warns against excessive sleep and
sex and wine.
And proverbs recommends honesty in your business affairs and kindness and
loyalty and impartiality.
And sobriety and humility and restraint and sincerity.
Wealth is very nice,
but it's not to be desired at the,
uh,
at the cost of calmness and peace.
The wisdom sayings that appear in proverbs are usually these short two lines
sentences in which the second line runs parallel in some way to the first.
Um,
some scholars have classified the different kinds of parallelism you find in the
book of proverbs,
and I've,
I've written the three main forms up here,
an example of synonymous parallelism where the second line is essentially
synonymous with the first that's found in proverbs 22.
One.
It's a classic feature of Biblical poetry in general.
We'll see it in the psalms for an example.
A good name is to be chosen rather than great riches and favor,
parallel to good name is better than silver and gold,
right parallel to great riches.
So the two lines are,
are somewhat synonymous in antithetical parallelism.
The two lines form a balanced pair of opposites.
So in proverbs 10,
one,
a wise son makes a glad father,
but a foolish son is a sorrow to his mother.
When the second line seems to complete the thought of the first,
it's called ascending parallelism.
Um,
we find that in proverbs 1122 like a gold ring in the snout of a pig is a
beautiful woman bereft of sense.
Another feature of proverbs is that wisdom itself is established as a religious
concept.
It seems to have some religious value.
Proverbs tries to link wisdom with reverence for God and obedience to God.
In proverbs one seven,
the fear of the Lord of the reverence,
the fear of the Lord is the beginning of wisdom.
Fools despise wisdom and discipline.
Or chapter three verses five through eight.
Trust in the Lord with all your heart and do not rely on your own understanding.
Wisdom guards one from evil.
The wise person accepts the sufferings with which God is disciplining him.
So in proverbs three 12,
four Yahweh reproves or disciplines him whom he loves as a father,
the son in whom he delights.
Keep that in mind as we turn to joke because I think the most important thing
about the book of proverbs is it's almost smug certainty that the righteous and
the wicked of the world receive what they deserve in this life.
There's a complacency here and optimism.
God's just providence and a moral word or world order our presuppositions that
it just doesn't seem to question the wise persons.
Deeds are good and will bring them happiness and success.
The foolish persons deeds are evil and they're going to lead to failure and
ruin.
The key idea is that a truly wise person knows that the world is essentially
coherent.
It's ethically ordered.
There are clear laws of reward and punishment that exists in the world.
Proverbs 26 verse 27 he who digs a pit will fall into it and a stone.
We'll come back upon him.
Who starts it rolling or 13 six righteousness protects him.
Whose way is blameless?
Wickedness subverts the sinner.
If the righteous suffer,
then they're being chastised or chastened by God just as a son,
as disciplined by his father,
and he shouldn't reject this reproof.
He should welcome it.
And this insistence on the basic justice of the world and the power of wisdom or
fear of the Lord to guarantee success.
And security was one strand of ancient Israelite thought.
It reaches crystallization in the book of proverbs.
It was available as a response to,
or an explanation of the catastrophes that had befallen the nation.
We've seen it at work and the Deuteronomistic school unwilling to relinquish the
idea of a moral God in control of history and preferring,
preferring to infer the nations sinfulness from its suffering and calamity
better to blame the sufferer Israel.
And so keep God and the system of divine,
retributive justice intact.
But it's precisely this formulaic and conventional piety that is challenged by
two other remarkable wisdom books in the Bible,
the book of Job and the book of Ecclesiastes and enjoy.
We find the idea that suffering is not always punitive.
It is not always a sign of wickedness.
It's not always explicable.
And this is the first of several subversions of fundamental biblical principles
that we encounter in the book of job.
The book of job,
we really don't know,
uh,
it's date.
It's probably no earlier than the sixth century BCE.
But scholars disagree and there are portions of it that seemed to reflect a very
old and ancient,
very ancient tradition.
It's one of the hardest books of the Bible for moderns to read and I think
that's because its conclusions to the degree that we can agree on what the
conclusions might be,
but its conclusions seem to fly in the face of some basic religious convictions.
You have to allow yourself,
I think,
to be surprised,
to open your mind,
to allow yourself to take job's charges against God seriously.
After all the narrator,
it makes it clear that God does take them seriously.
God,
nowhere denies job's charges and in fact at one point the narrator has gods say
that job has spoken truly.
So no matter how uncomfortable job may make you feel,
you need to understand his claims and not condemn him.
Job is going to attack the optimistic conventional piety that is typified in the
book of proverbs.
He's going to challenge the assumption that there is a moral world order.
The issues that are raised in this book are two fold.
First,
why God permits blatant injustice and undeserved suffering and evil to exist in
the world.
And second of all,
whether people will be virtuous when they are afflicted and suffering.
In other words,
are people righteous only because God will reward them for it?
Or are they righteous because of the intrinsic and inherent value of
righteousness?
Those are the two issues that literarily the book contains two primary elements.
First,
we have a pros story and that provides a framework for the book.
That's chapters one and two,
and then it returns in chapter 42 at the end of the book,
uh,
and into this prose narrative,
this,
this pros framework,
a large poetic section of dialogue and speeches has been inserted.
Okay,
so there are two main literary components.
Now,
the pros framework concerning a scrupulously righteous man named job afflicted
by horrendous calamity was probably a standard ancient near eastern folk tale of
great antiquity.
The story isn't set in Israel.
It's not about an Israelite.
It's set in Edam job is an eastern magnate who dwells in the country of ooze.
Uh,
not an Israelite,
but the Israelite author has used this older,
ancient near eastern legend about a man named job for his own purposes.
Then named job,
which in Hebrew is pronounced Yoav,
um,
is sort of by Vaillant in meaning it can mean enemy and Hebrew,
by changing vowels around.
But it's the route is the route for enemy or you have,
or if we take it in Aramaic,
it can mean one who repents a repentant one.
And as we're going to see,
um,
the name will be appropriate in both senses as the story progresses.
I've given,
oh,
there's a handout on the side of the room.
I'm not sure everyone took them when they came in.
I'm wondering if it could be distributed please.
I'm sorry.
It's going to help you chart,
uh,
what goes on in job.
But this handout contains an outline of the book structure on one side.
So that's mapped out on one side.
On the other side,
I have some important versus in terms,
but we'll see from the outline of the structure.
Chapters one and two have this pros prologue about the price and prosperous job.
And his devastation,
which result,
which is the result of a challenge,
which is put to God at the end of that prologue.
So at the end of chapter two,
he has three friends who come to sit with him in silence for seven days.
Silence doesn't last very long.
Um,
because we move then into the large poetic section and that extends from chapter
three all the way to chapter 42 verse seven.
All right,
so you'll see that structure on the handout,
there are many ways to map the structure of the,
of the book of job.
Um,
your handout charts.
I think one of the more common and and,
and clearer representations.
I'm looking now specifically at the poetic section.
First you have a dialogue between job and his three friends that goes from
third,
from chapter three to chapter 31 verse 40.
And it can be divided into three cycles of speeches.
Job Opens each cycle.
So the first speech in each cycle is by job.
And then his friends speak in a regular pattern.
First,
Ellie fas with Joe Responding and then bill Dodd with Joe responding.
And then so far,
and you have this pattern of six speeches,
it occurs three times,
but in fact,
the third time,
um,
the reply by it so far is omitted and that deviation ensures the job has the
first and the last word.
Um,
he has a summation speech in chapters 29 to 31.
At first,
the friends seek to comfort job,
uh,
and to explain his suffering,
but they become increasing increasingly harsh,
ultimately bearing a callous contempt for job's condition.
Um,
now this section closes with the long speech by job,
as I said,
29 to 31.
He's lamenting the loss of his past pleasant life.
He protested his innocence,
he calls on God to answer,
but then Ellie,
who this previously unannounced fourth friend appears,
he gives four speeches from chapters 32 to 37.
He admonishes job,
he defends God's justice.
And then this is followed by a poetic discourse between God and Job God who
poses a series of rhetorical questions and Jobe who appears contrite.
And that section also falls into four parts.
Rather like Ellie who's speech you have two long speeches by halfway,
two short ones by job.
Finally,
there's a concluding pros epilogue that vindicates job,
God criticizes job's friends,
and then in a rather unexpected happy ending,
we have job restored to his fortunes and finally experiencing a peaceful death.
So let's look at the contents in greater detail.
Now that we've reviewed the structure,
the story opens by introducing us to job.
He said to be a blameless and upright man.
He fears God and he shuns evil.
That is chapter one verse one.
So the moral virtue and innocence of job is established in the opening line as a
narrative fact,
a non negotiable narrative fact.
And yet this job is to become the victim of a challenge issued by the Sutton in
the heavenly council.
I say,
thus the time deliberately,
the Sutton,
that's the tongue is certainly not the devil.
There's no such notion in the Hebrew Bible.
The phrase,
thus aton occurs four times in the Hebrew Bible here and in numbers 22 and in
Zechariah three thus a ton is simply a member of the divine council,
one of God's minions whose function it is to investigate a on earth and to act
as a kind of prosecuting attorney.
He has to bring evildoers to justice and it's only in later Jewish and
especially Christian thought that the term loses the definite article from the
Sutton,
which means the prosecutor,
essentially the prosecuting attorney and becomes a proper name,
capital s Satan for an enemy or opponent of God.
This later concept of Satan develops as a means of explaining evil without
attributing it to God,
but that isn't the function of the Sutton.
Here he works for God and when Cafe boasts of his pious servant Jobe,
the prosecuting Angel wonders as his portfolio requires him to do whether job's
piety is sincere,
perhaps he's motivated by self interest.
Since he's been blessed with such good fortune and prosperity,
he's naturally enough pious and righteous,
but would his piety survive affliction and suffering,
deprived of his wealth?
Wouldn't he curse God to his face?
And you have to notice as you're reading the the euphemistic use of blessed God
instead of curse God.
Ancient writers did not want to write down curse God.
So they wrote,
bless God,
but we need to understand that.
So euphemistic way of avoiding writing curse got so wouldn't he curse God to his
face?
And God is quite confident that job's piety is not superficial.
It's not driven by the desire for reward.
And so he permits this aton to put job to the test.
Job's children are killed,
his cattle are destroyed,
his property is destroyed,
but job's response in chapter one verse 21 is naked.
I came from my mother's womb and naked I shall return.
God gives and God takes away.
May the name of the Lord be blessed.
And the narrator then adds in verse 22 in all this,
and if you flip over,
I've got some of these key versus on the back of your handout to help you keep
track.
But in all this job did not sin or impute anything unsavory to God and God
again,
praises job to the Satan.
This aton excuse me,
saying and still he holds onto his integrity.
So you incited me to destroy him for nothing.
That's chapter two verse three.
So this aton proposes increasing the suffering and God agrees on the condition
that job's life be preserved.
So this baton strikes job's body with these terrible,
painful sores trying to crush his spirit and job's wife rages.
Do you still hold on to your integrity?
Bless God,
curse God and die.
Chapter two verse nine but still,
Joe will not sin.
He will not curse God.
He insists on remaining virtuous and he responds,
shall we receive good at the hand of God and shall We not receive evil?
So at first glance,
it would appear that job accepts his bitter fate.
But note,
after the first round of suffering,
the narrator observed that in all this job did not sin with his lips or impute
anything unsavory to God.
But now he merely observes in all this job did not sin with his lips,
not with his lips perhaps,
but in his heart did he impute unsavory things to God?
And if we were to move directly to the conclusion of the folktale in chapter 42
if jumped from this point just to the conclusion in 42 verse seven is where the
conclusion begins,
we would find that job is rewarded fully for his patients and his steadfast
loyalty and his household and his belongings are restored to him twice over the
folktale standing alone could be read as the story of an innocent man tested who
accepts his faith.
He have his fate,
he retains his faith and he's rewarded standing alone.
The tail appears to reflect the values and the conventional piety of the wisdom
literature and of the Deuteronomistic school.
But the folktale doesn't stand alone.
The anonymous author of job uses this earlier legend concerning the righteous
man job as a frame for his own purposes.
And the hint at the end of the prologue,
that job perhaps is beginning to impute unsavory things to God points forward to
this extensive poetic dialogue.
Um,
that's following.
And here our job's unsavory accusations against God.
Here we have a most impatient and furious job who will charge God with gross
mismanagement of the world.
And eventually deny the existence of a moral order altogether.
So reading the book of job is a fascinating exercise because the two types of
material in the book,
the pros frame and the poetic dialogue in the middle,
they appear to be intention and yet interwoven as they are.
Now they work together and the one shapes our reading of the other,
our reception of the accusations of job's friends in the poetic dialogue,
our reception of those words is determined by the pros frameworks assertion that
Joe was innocent.
That's a nonnegotiable narrative fact.
And because of that fact of job's righteousness,
we know job's friends are lying when they say Joe must be suffering for some
hidden sin.
And we know that job's self defense that he hasn't deserved the suffering is
correct.
We're going to rehearse some of the arguments that are advanced in the central
core of the poetic core of the book.
Um,
and here I think a helpful guide through the argument.
There are lots of,
lots of commentaries on the book of job.
Um,
but one commentary that I think is helpful in just sort of working through some
of the arguments of the interlocutors is the analysis of Edwin.
Good.
Although job doesn't exactly curse God in his first speech,
he does curse the day of his birth and in a passage that alludes repeatedly to
creation job essentially curses all that God has accomplished as creator of the
cosmos.
He wishes he were dead and at this point he doesn't even ask why this has
happened to him.
He only asks why he should be alive when he prefers death and Eleaf has his
reply is long and elaborate and he seems to offer comfort.
He seems to offer comfort until he injects a new element in the discussion.
And that's the element of justice.
Job hasn't mentioned the issue of justice at this point,
but Ellie fas says,
think now what innocent man ever perished?
Where have the upright been destroyed?
As I seen those who plow evil and so mischief reap them.
Chapter four,
verses seven and eight.
So eleaf has his hand in job.
The Standard Line of Biblical wisdom literature as exemplified by something like
the book of proverbs,
belief in a system of divine retro,
retributive justice,
right?
That retribution is just by definition there can be no undeserved suffering.
The implication is that job has deserved this suffering.
A thought that apparently hadn't occurred to Joe,
and the question of undeserved suffering is now going to dominate the rest of
the discussion and job.
Second speech is very disorderly.
It's full of wild,
contradictory images that may reflect the shock and the pain and the rage that
now overwhelmed him.
He seems to be haunted by Eleaf has his connection of his suffering with some
sin,
and so he turns to address God directly.
He admits he's not perfect,
but surely he objects he doesn't deserve such affliction.
And in Chapter Eight we have Bill Dad's speech and it's tactless and unkind.
He says,
well,
God,
pervert the right will,
the Almighty pervert justice.
If your son's sinned against him,
he dispatched them for their transgressions.
In other words,
God is perfectly just and ultimately all get what they deserve.
Indeed your children job must've died because they sinned.
So just search for God and ask for mercy.
The friends speeches lead job to the conclusion that God must be indifferent to
moral status.
God doesn't follow the rules that he demands of human beings.
It's chapter nine verse 22 he finishes off both perfect and wicked when job
complains,
he wounds me much for nothing.
Chapter nine verse 17 he's echoing God's own words to the Sutton in the
prologue.
Remember,
when God says to this,
it's on,
you have incited me to destroy him for nothing.
And we suspect by this verbal coincidence that job is right.
Legal terms dominate as job calls for the charges against him to be published.
And then he hurls countercharges in a suit against God,
charges of unworthy conduct of spurning his creatures while smiling on the
wicked on scrutinizing job,
even though he knows job to be innocent.
And this too is a subversion of a comic common prophetic literary genre that
we've seen,
right?
The Reeve or the Covenant lawsuit in which God through his prophets charges
Israel with flagrant a flagrant violation of the terms of the covenant and warns
of inevitable punishment here in job.
It's a man who arranged God and yet job asserts.
Since God is God and not a human adversary,
there's really no fair way for the lawsuit between them to be tried or
arbitrated.
Man Cannot win a suit against God.
Chapter nine verse two job is powerless in the face of this injustice.
These ideas,
I'll find expression in job 10 verses one through seven I am disgusted with
life.
I will give rain to my complaints,
speak in the bitterness of my soul.
I say to do not condemn me.
Let me know what you charge me with.
Does it benefit you to defraud,
to despise the toil of your hands while smiling on the counsel of the wicked?
Do you have the eyes of flesh?
Is your vision that of mere man are your days,
the days of a mortal?
Are Your years,
the years of a man that you seek my iniquity and search out my sin?
You know that I am not guilty and that there is none to deliver from your hand.
Joe Repeats his wish to die this time less because of the suffering and more
because his worldview has collapsed.
He sees that divine power is utterly divorced from justice and that's a second
fundamental biblical assumption.
Subverted,
but job's words only seem to egg his interlocutors.
On eleaf.
Oz had implied that Joe was a sinner.
Bill Dodd had baldly asserted that his son had died for their sins and now it's
so far it's going to claim that actually job is suffering less than he deserves
and job isn't persuaded.
He hasn't persuaded that he has sinned or more precisely that he has sinned in
proportion to the punishment.
He is now suffering.
God is simply unjust.
The job of this poetic dialogue portion of the book is hardly patient or pious.
He is angry,
he's violent.
He argues,
he complains,
and he vehemently insists upon his innocence in the fourth speech by job.
Now this is the speech that opens the second cycle of speeches.
Job Appeals to creation.
God's controlling power is arbitrary and unprincipled.
He interferes with the natural order.
He interferes with the human order.
And this is itself a subversion of the genesis portrait of creation as a process
whose goal and crown is humankind.
Again,
job demands a trial.
He demands a trial in the widely quoted and miss translated verse.
This is job 13,
verse 15.
He may well slay me.
I have no hope,
but I must argue my case before him.
In other words,
job knows that he can't win,
but he still wants his day in court.
He wants to make his accusation of God's mismanagement.
He wants to voice his protest even though he knows that we'll gain him nothing.
And in a pun on his name,
Yoav Job Asks God,
why do you hide your face and treat me like an enemy?
Treat me like an oh you have.
Um,
13 verse 28 in his second speech,
job fully expects to be murdered,
not executed,
but murdered by God and hopes only that the evidence of his murder will not be
concealed.
He says in 16 verse 18,
Earth do not cover my blood and job's third speech.
Reiterate this desire,
the desire that the wrong against him not be forgotten would that my words were
written would that they were engraved in an inscription with an iron stylists
and led forever in rock.
They were incised.
Chapter 19 Verses 23 to 24 job's three speeches in the second cycle become
increasingly emotional and for their part,
the speeches of his friends in this cycle become increasingly cruel.
Their insistence that suffering is always a sign of sure.
A sure sign of sin seems to justify,
um,
hostility towards and contempt for job.
He's now depicted as universally mocked and humiliated and despised and abused
and one cannot help but see in this characterization of job's friends,
so-called friends and incisive commentary on the Callus,
human propensity to blame the victim and to do so.
Let's start tidy and comfortable picture of a moral universe in which the
righteous do not suffer,
should come apart at the seams.
As job's has job opens the third cycle of speeches,
urging his friends to look to really see his situation.
Because if they did,
they would be appalled.
Job's situation looked at honestly requires the admission that God has done this
for no reason and that the friends understanding of the world is a lie.
Job Asserts baldly.
There is no distributor of justice.
There's no coherent or orderly system of morality in this life or any other.
There is no principle of afterlife after all in the Hebrew Bible Chapter 21
verses seven through 26 why do the wicked live on prosper and grow wealthy?
Their children are with them always and they see their children's children.
Their homes are secure without fear.
They do not feel the rod of God,
their children's skip about.
They sing to the music of Timberland,
loot and revel to the tune of the pipe.
They spend their days and happiness and go down to Shay,
Ole and peace.
How seldom does the lamp of the wicked fail does the calamity they deserve
befall them?
You say God is reserving his punishment for his sons.
Let it be paid back to him that he may feel it.
One man dies and robust,
healthful,
tranquil and untroubled.
His pails are full of milk is the marrow of his bones.
His juicy.
Another dies embittered,
never having tasted happiness.
They both lie in the dust and are covered with worms,
but the friends can't look honestly at job.
They can't allow that.
Indeed a righteous man suffers horribly by the end of the third cycle.
Job is ready and eager for his trial,
but he can't find God.
Job's final speech in the third cycle focuses on this theme of divine absence.
God is irresponsibly absent from the world and the result is human wickedness.
So from the idea that God is morally neutral or indifferent,
job has moved to the implicit charge that God is responsible for wickedness.
He rewards,
we can just see causes wickedness by his absence,
his failure to govern properly.
He is both corrupt and a corruptor of others.
If it is not.
So he says,
who will prove me a liar and bring my words to not.
And yet even in the depths of his anguish,
and even though he is now convinced that God does not enforce a moral law in the
uniform,
in the universe,
job clings to one value.
Righteousness is a virtue in and of itself.
And even if it brings no reward,
job will not give up his righteousness face to face with a shocking insight that
good and evil are met with indifference by God.
That righteousness brings no reward and wickedness.
No punishment job,
although bitter refuses to succumb to a moral neorealism.
Chapter 26 verses two through six by God who has deprived me of justice by Shit,
die who has embittered my life as long as there is life in me and God's breath
is in my nostrils,
my lips will speak no wrong nor my tongue utter deceit far be it from me to say
that you are right until I die,
I will maintain my integrity.
I persist in my righteousness and will not yield.
I shall be free of reproach as long as I live.
And these last lines recall called the words of God.
And this aton in the prelude at the time had said that a man will not hold on to
virtue or to righteousness in the face of suffering,
you'll give everything away for his life.
So this narrative setup guides or influences our interpretation of job's
statement here.
Although he is losing his life,
job says he will not give anything away,
but he holds on to.
He maintains his integrity just as God had scolded this aton in chapter two
verse three which reads still,
he holds onto his integrity.
You have incited me to destroy him for nothing.
So in his darkest,
most bitter hour,
with all hope of reward,
gone,
job clings to the one thing he has his own righteousness.
In fact,
when all hope of adjust,
reward is gone,
then righteousness becomes an intrinsic value.
It has scaled Koufman writes of this moment the poet raises job to the bleak
summit of righteousness,
bereft of hope,
bereft of faith and divine justice.
Or in the words of another scholar,
Moshe Greenberg.
We see here the sheer heroism of a naked man for seek and by his God and his
friends and bereft of a clue to understand his suffering,
still maintaining faith in the value of his virtue and in the absolute duty of
man to be virtuous.
The universe has turned its back on him.
We may add,
he believes God has turned his back on him,
yet Joe persists in the affirmation of his own worth and the transcendent worth
of unrewarded.
Good.
So in a way then for all their differences and style and manner,
the patient job of the legend and the raging job of the poetic dialogue are
basically the same man each ultimately remains from and his moral character
cleaned to righteousness because of its intrinsic value and not because it will
be rewarded.
Indeed job knows bitterly that it will not at the end of his outburst job Suze
God,
he issued him a summons and he demands that God revealed to him the reason for
his suffering job pronounces a series of curses to clear himself from the
accusations against him specifying the sins he has not committed an ending as he
began in chapter three with a curse on the day of his birth.
And we expect to hear from God now,
but instead we hear from an unannounced stranger Ellie,
who I'm going to have to give Ellie who short shrift.
Um,
he's the only one of the four interlocutors to refer to Joe by name,
address Joe by name.
He retired.
He repeats many of the trite assertions of job's friends.
He does hint,
um,
however,
that not all suffering is punitive.
He also hints that contemplation of Nature's elements can open the mind to a new
awareness of God.
And in these two respects,
Ellie,
who's speech moves us towards God's answer from the storm.
So in the climactic moment,
God answers job in an extraordinary theophany or self manifestation.
And Chapter 38 God speaks out of the tempest,
a whirlwind.
Who is this who darkens counsel speaking without knowledge?
Is he referring to Joe?
To Ellie,
who?
The three friends.
All of them,
God has heard enough.
It's his turn to ask questions.
The answers to which are clearly implied.
These are rhetorical questions.
Where were you when I laid the earth's foundations?
Speak.
If you have understanding,
do you know who fixed its dimensions are?
Who measured it with a line?
You did.
God.
Have you ever commanded the day to break assigned the dawn?
It's place.
Have you penetrated to the sources of the sea or walked in the recesses of the
deep?
No.
Human has and got continues with these rhetorical questions.
Questions regarding the animals,
they're various powers and attributes,
but one wonders what the purpose of all these questions is.
One senses that they are irrelevant.
Job has posed some very specific challenges to God.
Why am I suffering?
Is there a pattern to existence?
Is God's refusal to answer these challenges a way of saying there is no answer
or is it God's way of saying that justice is beyond human understanding or is
this the often the of God in nature and the focus on creation and implicit
assault on the fundamental tenant of Israelite religion that God is known and
made manifest to his interactions with humans is rewards and punishments and
historical time.
You'll recall that the monotheistic revolution is generally understood to have
affected a break from mythological conceptions of the gods as indistinguishable
from various natural forces limited by Mehta,
divine powers and forces of the cosmos.
The biblical God wasn't another ancient near eastern or Canaanite nature,
God ultimately,
uh,
but a wholly transcendent power.
He was figured this way in many parts of the Bible known not through the
involuntary and recurring cycles of nature,
but through his freely willed and non repeating actions in historical time.
Such a view of God underwrites the whole system of divine,
retributive justice,
only an essentially good God who transcends and is unconstrained by mechanistic.
Natural forces can establish and administer a system of retributive justice,
dealing out punishment and reward in response to the actions of humans in time
is the author of job's suggesting that history and the events that befall the
just and the unjust are not the medium of revelation.
Is God a god of nature after all encountered in the repeating cycles of the
natural world and not in the unpredictable and incoherent arena of human history
and action?
If so,
then this is a third fundamental biblical assumption that has been radically
subverted.
So we'll turn now to God's direct speech to job in 48 and 40 verse eight.
Excuse me.
What do you impugn my justice?
Would you condemn me that you'd be right and God,
I think is now getting at the heart of the matter.
Your friend's job were wrong.
They condemned you,
they attributed sin to you so that they might be right,
but you two have been wrong condemning me,
attributing wickedness to me so that you might be right.
Job's friends aired because they assumed that there's a system of retributive
justice at work in the world,
and that assumption led them to infer that all who suffer are sinful,
and that's a blatant falsehood,
but job also heirs.
If he assumes that although there isn't a system of retributive justice,
there really ought to be one,
and it's that assumption that leads him to infer that suffering is the sign of
an indifferent or wicked God,
and that's equally a falsehood.
Job needs to move beyond the anthropocentric,
the anthropocentrism that characterizes the rest of scripture and the genesis
one account of creation according to which humankind is the goal of the entire
process of creation.
God's creation.
The book of job seems to suggest defies such teleological and rational
categories.
In a nutshell,
God refuses to be seen as a moral accountant.
The idea of God is a moral accountant is responsible for two major errors,
the interpretation of suffering as an indicator of sin or the description of
injustice to God and in his final speech,
job confesses to a new job,
excuse me,
job confesses to a new firsthand knowledge of God that he lacked before.
And as a result of this knowledge,
job repents.
Therefore I recant and relent being but dust and ashes.
Chapter 42 verse six and here we see the other meaning of job's name,
one who repents suddenly leap to the fore.
What is he repenting of?
Certainly not of sin.
God has not upheld the accusations against job.
Indeed,
he states explicitly in a moment that the friends were wrong to say he had
sinned,
but he has indicated that guilt and innocence,
reward and punishment are not what the game is all about.
And while job had long been disabused of the notion that the wicked and the
righteous actually get what they deserve,
he nevertheless had clung to the idea that ideally they should,
and it's that mistaken idea,
that idea that led him to a scribe wickedness to God,
that job now recants with this new understanding of God job is liberated from
what he would now see as a false expectation raised by the Deuteronomistic
notion of a covenant relationship between God and humankind and forced by a
system of divine justice.
They end of the story.
Job is fully restored to his fortunes.
God asserts he did no evil,
and the conventional impeccably Deuteronomistic view of the three friends is
clearly denounced by God.
He says of them,
they have not spoken of me.
What is right as my servant job has?
For some,
the happy ending seems anticlimactic,
a capitulation to the demand for a happy ending of just desserts that runs
counter to the whole thrust of the book,
and yet in a way,
I think the ending is superbly fitting.
It's the last in a series of reversals that subverts our expectations.
Suffering comes inexplicably sodas,
restoration.
Blessed be the name of the Lord.
God doesn't attempt to justify or explain job's suffering.
And yet somehow by the end of the book are grumbling,
Dis dis,
um,
disable are grumbling,
embittered,
raging job is satisfied.
Perhaps he's realized that an automatic principle of reward and punishment would
make it impossible for humans to do the good for purely disinterested motives.
It's precisely when righteousness is seemed to be absurd and meaningless,
that the choice to be righteous paradoxically becomes meaningful.
God and job,
however we are to interpret their speeches are reconciled.
The suffering and injustice that characterize the world have baffled humankind
from Millennia.
And the book of job provides no answer in the sense of an explanation or a
justification of suffering and injustice.
But what it does offer is a stern warning to avoid the Scylla of blast feeling
against the victims by assuming their wickedness and the Caribbeans of
blaspheming against God by assuming his nor his moral Neil ism and option as our
hero yearning for,
but ultimately renouncing divine order.
And justice clings to his integrity and chooses virtue for nothing.